un pedido por la acción climática
inmediata dos días antes de los comicios
en alemania miles de jóvenes se
concentraron frente al parlamento alemán
liderados por la popular activista
medioambiental creta chamber que apeló
al voto pero criticó la inacción
política y llamó a las manifestantes a
convertirse en activistas climáticos
ningún partido está ni siquiera cerca de
proponer una vía que sea coherente con
el acuerdo de parís y sin votar es
esencial pero por sí solo no es
suficiente si queremos garantizar una
presencia y un futuro seguro para el
planeta tierra tenemos que tener
ciudadanos democráticos activos y salir
a la calle como estamos haciendo hoy
la activista calificó a alemania de uno
de los mayores villanos del clima
apuntando a que se trata del cuarto
mayor emisor de co2 de la historia la
crisis climática está en la agenda
mundial incluso con muchas de las
intervenciones de los líderes mundiales
ante la asamblea general de naciones
unidas también en alemania que
recientemente sufrió las consecuencias
del calentamiento global con masivas
inundaciones que dejaron cientos de
muertos fue uno de los temas de campaña
de los candidatos a la cancillería pero
los manifestantes no creen en sus
discursos light desgraciadamente siempre
pasa lo mismo la política no hace nada
pero creo que es especialmente
importante enviar una señal hoy antes de
las elecciones federales que son el
domingo y espero que sobretodo mucha
gente de la generación adulta se
replanteé su voto al ver cuántos jóvenes
están preocupados por el futuro
desde londres hasta india el movimiento
fried es for future regreso a las calles
tras un parón obligado por la pandemia
de kobe 19 miles de jóvenes de todo el
mundo exigen de nuevo justicia climática